[Music]
this week
influential activist feminist leader
dorothy pittman-hughes was given some
overdue recognition
with the dedication of a plaque in her
honor in her hometown of lumpkin georgia
hughes was a founding force in emerging
social movements
that are now well established including
women's rights
in fact 50 years ago when this photo was
taken
she was about to embark on a speaking
tour with feminist
icon gloria steinem who's remained a
lifelong fan
friend and fellow activist
pittman-hughes has now retired from
public life but we sat down with those
closest to her
including steinum to honor her life's
work
this year the press has finally
discovered a movement
when gloria steinem brought her
kaleidoscope life to the big screen
hello she made certain her partner in
the struggle for women's rights
my name is dorothy pitman hughes
portrayed by janelle monae
was prominently featured that too many
women are being forced to leave their
children home alone
while they work to be their families
feminist
child welfare advocate pioneering
businesswoman
i knew that dorothy was absolutely
fearless it was always
clear that if she was running the
revolution you wanted to go to it
[Laughter]
dorothy pittman-hughes was already a
player when steinem profiled her in new
york magazine
in 1969. she had created the first
child care center non-sexist
multi-racial child care center
in new york city and also she was a kind
of genius
street organizer of all the merchants
along 125th street
and beyond founder of the city's first
battered women's shelter
and new york's agency for child
development pittman hughes also
established the women's
action alliance with steinum we believe
that the alliance and an emphasis
on local action a national information
center specializing in children's
education
she was a bit of a spitfire wasn't she
absolutely
no completely she was always organizing
demonstrations
to protest the conditions in welfare
hotels for instance
i mean just massive massive
demonstrations women earn approximately
half of what men do
steinham too had made a name for herself
[Music]
arguing that racial and economic
inclusivity
was vital to the gender equality
movement if you
recognize discrimination in one form
you're more likely to
recognize it in another but black women
have always been
in the leadership of the women's
movement why were you so
open to hearing all voices and
recognizing all voices
in this movement most of the women are
in the world are not white a tiny
proportion of us
so it just seemed natural
to look at women as a group
and when i was with a group of women
that didn't look like the country
to say why now fast friends
they hit the speaking circuit touring
the country
with two goals went over minds to gender
equity
and tighten up steinem speaking skills
she taught me that i didn't die
if i got up in front of an audience this
was crucial
she taught me that actually the whole
point was to speak the way
we do in everyday life the way we do to
each other the way we do in the street
not in an artificial
way those two years on the road took
their toll on pitman hughes three
daughters
but her eldest deletia ridley maupston
says the cause was worth it i think by
the age 14
i realized that she was helping a lot of
people even though she wasn't always
there
with us she was helping a lot of other
people and it's kind of what we grew up
in my family born in lumpkin georgia
she fled the south five years after her
father was nearly beaten to death by the
kkk
i was about six years old when she took
me back home to georgia
still she returned hoping once again
to change minds and they drove to
alabama
and other places throughout the south
looking to kind of
meet the kkk i mean they were out to
meet and interview and talk to these
people
and to change what they could when i was
eight
my mom moved my brother and i to my
aunt's house
oscar-nominated actress gabarae sidibe
says
her aunt dorothy was her greatest
example of womanhood
my aunt didn't have a husband
and she was the only person i knew that
had a house
that had it upstairs and i remember
realizing that she had all of this
she had this entire house that she owned
i didn't realize that i could be a
an actualized person without a man and
she
is the first person to show me that for
citabay
and legions of others a single photo
personifies
all of that now in the national portrait
gallery smithsonian collection
and dorothy never let me forget that i
didn't know how to make a fist
that i had my thumb out instead of in we
did a version of the same photograph
as old ladies and she was still telling
me how to make a fist
her power and presence at long last
being recognized with a plaque
dedication this week
in her hometown of lumpkin georgia now
living in florida with her daughter
she met over the last year with steinum
to celebrate her 82nd birthday
over soon you know we're not afraid to
move ourselves
in the direction of caring about people
so i would think that anything you want
to
do call me we'll get it done
forever pittman-hughes has taken a back
seat these days
focusing on family but those closest to
her
have continued the legacy and the
lessons she taught
so many if we understand leadership as
it truly
exists which is truth-telling in the
moment
whether it's at a lunch counter or at a
street meeting
or in a lecture or wherever it is
just first of all listening to everyone
you know being a leader doesn't mean
talking endlessly on the contrary
it means listening and thus making
people
know that they are worth listening to
you know their friendship their
partnership produced so much when they
would walk into the room they really had
this incredible presence
welcomed by many people sometimes not so
much one of the funniest stories
steinham told me
was they were talking and you know often
people would attack them
and would say you know are you two
lesbians and she said
are you the alternative and everyone
fell out it just
dispersed you know all of that
negativity because it just drowned out
what folks who were against them were
out there trying to do and
labeling them as something didn't matter
what they were
they were trying to include they wanted
inclusion of all these women
nice people he's called the glorious yes
it's
thank you jeff